[Aplausos]
[Música]
gracias
cuántos de ustedes conocen el refrán que
mucho abarca poco aprieta
es ahora conocidísimo yo lo escuché un
montón de veces
y la verdad que desde siempre he tenido
problemas con esta frase
de hecho cuando era niño al pensar en
este refrán lo único que podía
imaginarme era alguien que por mucho
usará barcas grandes no le apretaban
bien los pies
yo sé no es una imagen muy buena pero
voy a poner como excusa que se da estaba
perdido totalmente con la gramática
española
cuando cuando supe que no tiene nada que
ver con abarcas o con los pies
cuando comprendí que tiene que ver con
el enfoque para poder tener éxito en la
vida
una parte de mí todavía pensaba en lo
triste que son refrán como este
es una frase que te aconseja evitar
hacer muchas cosas por el riesgo a no
hacer nada bien
esto es tremendamente desalentador no
cree en el asumir que no tenemos la
capacidad como seres humanos de hacer
una diversidad de cosas y hacerlas bien
esto en parte viene como resultado de
una sociedad industrializada
por ende una sociedad especializada
aprendemos desde muy temprano que la
clave del éxito es dirigirnos por un
camino singular
y trabajar para ser buenos en ese campo
específico
si bien para muchas personas esta
experiencia o este método funciona muy
bien
para mí esto involucraba abandonar un
montón de proyectos un montón de
intereses que no iban por un camino
singular pero que me apasionaban de
igual manera
por eso durante años pensé que yo era
una persona dispersa que no tenía la
capacidad de enfocarme y que por eso no
lograría hacer nada serio en mi vida
ahora que comprendo mejor mi situación
me doy cuenta de que esta dispersión en
realidad no es una desventaja sino todo
lo contrario es una pluralidad de
conocimientos
esto se define como paul y mattia
un poli mata es un individuo que posee
conocimientos y habilidades en diversas
disciplinas
podríamos definir un poli mata también
como un generalista ya que va en una
dirección opuesta a la especialización
al especialista
y si hoy le hablo del deseo y les
mencionó la polis mattia no es con
intención de disminuir el valor de la
especialización
hemos llegado a la sociedad la que
estamos ahora principalmente por el gran
aporte de los especialistas en la
industrialización de los últimos siglos
mi intención es más bien brindar una
perspectiva distinta un punto de vista
muy poco conocido para todas las
personas que como yo
no encajamos en el campo de la
especialización y que de alguna u otra
manera en algún momento dado se han
visto presionados a limitar sus
motivaciones y su potencial
para todas esas personas que se sienten
algo dispersas por la diversidad de sus
de sus intereses todos esos polis matas
en esta sala paul y metas en nuestra
sociedad
no subestimen esa diversidad de
intereses y sobre todo no limiten su
potencial
en búsqueda de un enfoque una
especialización si ésta no se siente
bien en la propia piel
para entender mejor la polis mattia es
importante hablar sobre el proceso de
aprendizaje que hace de un individuo un
poli mata
los polis matas cuentan con dos tipos de
acercamiento al conocimiento
cuando los intereses o las disciplinas
están conectadas entre sí se puede
definir esto como un proceso de
aprendizaje dirigido
en mi caso por ejemplo es un tipo es un
ejemplo de este tipo de política soy
diseñadora industrial trabajo en diseño
gráfico de empaque diseño de modas
edición fotográfica soy artista plástico
pintor todas estas disciplinas están
conectadas por un hilo creativo un hilo
del mundo del diseño y el mundo del arte
sin embargo estas disciplinas son
disciplinas totalmente independientes
las unas de las otras
cuando los intereses o las disciplinas
de un poli mata
no están conectadas entre sí y no
pretenden estarlo
se define como un proceso de aprendizaje
oportunista
por ejemplo un ingeniero civil que
también es músico una pediatra que
también es historiadora y fotógrafa
existen muchísimos casos de este tipo de
polimat y en la historia
para mí en lo particular uno de los
ejemplos más importantes e intimidantes
es leonardo da vinci
que aparte de ser escultor pintor
ingeniero arquitecto e historiador
trabajaba en campos de la cartografía
anatomía una lista interminable no
tenemos tiempo suficiente para hablar
sobre todos sus talentos sin embargo al
mencionar a leonardo davinci es
importante mencionar lo evidente su
genialidad
la genialidad no es una característica
exclusiva o indispensable para la polis
matía
un poli mate es un individuo que posee
conocimientos en diversos oficios no es
un individuo que resulta ser un genio en
una variedad de disciplinas
no todos los polímeros son genios
y no todos los genios son poli matas
ustedes tal vez se preguntarán ok cómo
saber si uno es poli matón o además que
implica la poli matías en la vida
cotidiana o cuál es el aporte del poli
mata en la sociedad que lo hace tan
especial bueno chicos un poquito de
paciencia no hagan tantas preguntas a la
vez que yo poco a poco les respondo
cómo saber si unes polimat o no
creo fielmente que todos los seres
humanos tenemos la capacidad de ser
polimitas
esto no significa necesariamente que
tengamos esta capacidad en el mismo
grado pero independientemente de si uno
se considera poli mata especialista
generalista o lo que sea la polis mattia
brinda a la sociedad en general un
enfoque distinto al aprendizaje y al
conocimiento y esto me lleva un poco a
responder las otras preguntas
los polis matas o generalistas son
individuos que cuentan con una
curiosidad profunda pero sobre todo
constante viven en un constante
aprendizaje esta es una herramienta
esencial para el crecimiento humano lo
que aprendemos hoy puede mejorar
modificar o incluso contra decir
totalmente lo que hemos aprendido ayer
esto nos obliga a ver las cosas con un
grado de flexibilidad evita que nos
estanquemos con ideas arcaicas con
puntos de vista intolerantes al cambio
además en el caso de los polis matas
este constante aprendizaje va
relacionado con oficios nuevos por lo
que están familiarizados con lo
desconocido y esto también involucra
estar familiarizado con ese temor a
fallar
para el poli mata el temor al fracaso no
es un gran obstáculo es un aspecto
circunstancial que brinda elementos
importantes de aprendizaje para el
camino
el poli mata ha vivido y superado el
fracaso muchas veces en muchos oficios
anteriores y es por eso que lo puede
hacer nuevamente
aquí quiero hacer un pequeño paréntesis
ya que estoy hablando sobre el temor a
fracasar para hablar sobre algo
relacionado
si es aconsejable evitar o por lo menos
disminuir nuestro nuestro temor a fallar
a fracasar
pero consideró también que es muy
importante y una muy buena señal el
tener algo de miedo al éxito
nuestras metas nuestros objetivos tienen
que darnos un mínimo de pánico cuando
pensamos en el éxito
si ustedes no tienen un solo gramo de
miedo a triunfar en sus sueños
es posible que estos sueños no sean lo
suficientemente grandes para ustedes
como generalistas aprendes con el tiempo
al contribuir en equipos complejos de
trabajo
que hay especialistas que saben más que
tú en temas específicos eso es obvio
pero como poli mata
tu aporte es distinto
tu forma de solucionar problemas cuenta
con la experiencia de todos tus
conocimientos y habilidades eso te
convierte en una especie de puente de
colaboración de mediación
ya que conoces de manera mucho más
profundas diversos lenguajes laborales
este es un aporte muy importante en una
sociedad actual y especializada
al final del día las disciplinas son
paul y mata independientemente lo
dispersas que sean se convierten en una
herramienta global para el
emprendimiento y éxito de los proyectos
tanto personales como laborales
en mi trabajo como artista plástico por
ejemplo uso una variedad de herramientas
que no están para nada conectadas con el
arte
pero me ayudan a desarrollar mi trabajo
de una manera mucho más eficiente mucho
más eficaz y mucho más estratégica
desarrollo y programación de páginas web
marketing edición fotográfica
profesional información técnica sobre
imprenta y material gráfico son son
disciplinas que nunca me han ayudado a
crear un cuadro pero me brindan mucho
más control tanto creativo como
ejecutiva en el momento de ser un
emprendedor personal e individual
este tipo de características del proceso
de aprendizaje y la forma de trabajo del
poli mata se puede aplicar de una manera
muy beneficiosa en una sociedad en
general
ahora más que nunca las herramientas
para aprender nuevos oficios para
actualizar nuestra información ampliar
nuestro conocimiento están a un alcance
inmediato
internet ha abierto mundos de
posibilidades que no estaban ahí hace
unas cuantas décadas atrás
plataformas como esta como ted ex y la
gran variedad de plataformas de
educación gratuita que existen en línea
nos abren las puertas a una nueva
polimat y a la poli mattia del nuevo
milenio
actualmente soy el encargado de diseño y
desarrollo de productos del museo
metropolitano de arte en nueva york'
uno de los museos de arte más grandes
del mundo
mi aplicación de trabajo compitió con
más de 400 diseñadores internacionales
supongo que se podrán imaginar lo
paralizado que estaba este yacuibeño
recién llegado la gran manzana al
recibir la noticia que obtuvo un trabajo
de tal tamaño
el trabajo que yo realizó en el museo
requiere muchos de mis oficios desde
diseño de productos hasta ilustración
para niños es un trabajo apto para un
poli matta creativo
y creo que he llegado hasta ahí por la
pasión y dedicación que he puesto en mis
intereses durante toda mi vida
si hay algo que puedo ofrecerle soy de
mi experiencia hasta este momento
es visibilizar la capacidad que tenemos
los seres humanos hacia la polis mattia
pero sobre todo el deber que tenemos
hacia nosotros mismos de dar libertad a
nuestros intereses sin importar los
dispersos o diversos que éstos sean
nunca sabes dónde te van a llevar tus
sueños cuando los alimentos con
dedicación y con constancia
debemos confiar mucho más en nuestra
capacidad y nuestra tenacidad personal
que en simples casillas sociales
podemos muy bien hacer todas las cosas
que deseamos hacer si estamos dispuestos
a trabajar duro por ello
y la próxima vez que piensen en la
diversidad de sus intereses y se sientan
un poco desorientados por esto
recuerden el que mucho abarca
simplemente tiene que apretar con un
poco más de fuerza
gracias
[Aplausos]